we have a very important runoff election
happening in Georgia on December 6th it
is Herschel Walker versus incumbent
Democratic senator Rafael Warnock this
will not decide who controls the Senate
Democrats will control the Senate but it
will decide do Democrats control 50 50
with Kamala Harris as the tie-breaking
vote or do Democrats control 5149 making
Kamala Harris unnecessary or creating a
little bit of margin in case Joe manchin
or Kirsten Cinema decide not to play
ball well as I've told you before
Herschel Walker the Republican candidate
is one of the most if not the most
unqualified candidate for the Senate I
can ever remember covering I've played
Four you times where Herschel Walker has
been incoherent where he's been visibly
disoriented where he has said nonsense
gobbledygook coming out of his mouth
all of those examples are nothing
compared to what I'm going to play for
you today
Herschel Walker
speaking a mile a minute I've never seen
this before this is upper Herschel
Walker on a rant about werewolves and
vampires that I challenge you I
challenge you
to make through the entire thing
listen to this I want you to keep the
faith
oh you ever watch a stupid movie late at
night hoping gonna get better don't get
better but keep watching it anyway
because other night the other night I
was watching this movie I was watching
this movie called Fright Night Freak
night or some type of night but it was
about vampires I don't know if you know
vampires and cool people are they not
but I'm gonna tell you something that I
found out a werewolf can kill a vampire
did you know that I never knew that so I
didn't want to be a vampire anymore I
want to be a werewolf but then anyway
elect this man watching this movie and
then you tell you how stupid it is
because it's one in the morning so I'm
watching my TV or these kids watching
their TV uh vampire kill on their TV
so you know it's kind of stupid but I'm
still watching though as I'm watching
this show what was funny these kids had
a vampire in that attic at their house
so they were watching that TV now I'm
watching my TV as they watching their TV
this is sad right is the sadder crazier
scary I don't know I mean I think the
scary part is that this guy might be a
senator
he's a Vampire killer on that TV so they
win this contest to bring this actor now
y'all gotta stay with me bring this
actor who's a Vampire killer from that
TV to get rid of this real life vampire
in that attic so it just actor comes to
their home he got all the right stuff he
got all the right stuff because you know
I got to have a state and got to have a
thing to kill him in the heart and he
got a necklace of garlic could that work
is anybody still with us here I don't
know what it does but it worked we gotta
have a cross because it burned I know
that worked and then all of a sudden
this is what was so funny about it and
they're walking through the house this
these this this guy's got the holy water
he blessing the house this actor now
he's all fake he's dressed in the house
with his holy water they walked upstairs
and this vampire looking real good in
this black suit whoa that sounds like
Senator or not doesn't it look at my all
good in this black suit floating I guess
that's the connection to the campaign
from the ceiling he floated from the
ceiling looking good and cool and I'm
thinking whoa they better get out of
that house and somebody float from your
ceiling get out of that house that's
that's not your house but as he floated
from the ceiling the kid jumped behind
that hero as they jump behind that hero
the guy jumped in front of this holy
water Threw It On The Vampire forehead
he covered his eyes
and he took his hand away we're almost
through it and the reason I'm playing
the whole thing is for you to realize
this was not just 10 seconds out of
context this was a two-minute
unintelligible hopped up rant he started
laughing and he said that don't work he
took the cross he put it on the vampire
forehead and the vampire didn't even do
anything he said that don't work and
that's the way it is in our life it
ain't working unless you got faith it is
time for us to have faith we got to have
faith in our fellow brother you got to
have faith in this country got to have
faith in this in the elected officials
and right now that's the reason I'm here
does anybody understand why he's there I
don't I'm from that explanation he says
that's why I'm here
I don't understand why he's there
folks do you understand the level of
Despair that we should all feel at the
state of democracy if this man can
become an American Senator a United
States Senator one of 100 Senators it is
extra important that we do everything we
can
to prevent him from becoming a senator
this is a humiliation this I quite I'm
not exaggerating okay
if I walked into guys I don't know a dry
cleaner if I walked into anywhere an
accounting firm and they said uh CPA
Walker is going to be handling your
taxes this year
and people the whoever comes in speaks
like this rants like this about things
I'm not hiring that person
and he's on the cusp of becoming a U.S
senator when Raphael Warnock understands
the issues
seems reasonably empathetic seems to
understand the process of the Senate I
mean what are we even talking about here
here's one more clip from this where
it's something about bicycles I I don't
even know it's it's wow but what we need
to do is get rid of those 87 000 RS
agents that's going to go after you
maybe we need to push now remember there
aren't 87 000 IRS or Ras agents that
it's just it's not true
remember that over the next decade 55
000 IRS agents will retire so there's a
plan to replace them with 55 000 new IRS
agents in addition the IRS is
understaffed so there's going to be a
slight increase to Staffing and in terms
of them going after people this is the
armed IRS agent's thing there's like a
very small division in the IRS I don't
remember if it's a couple hundred or at
the most like 1800 something like that
agents who carry firearms and like they
they are they are police at the end of
the day and police carry firearms
police officer and I was stood to
protect our kids that's what we need to
do that's what we need to do but yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah we got people in
Washington that gotten too weak all they
want to do is let people ride that bike
that's what Senator wanted to do is then
Joe Biden ride his bike because he voted
with him 96 of the time which means he
don't know what he's doing or he seem to
love Joe Biden I don't know which one it
is but I can tell you both of them is
wrong
it's it's really sad at the end of the
day I mean it just he doesn't make any
sense this is this is the embodiment of
everything we should be working really
hard to keep out of public office it's
it's everything it's everything it's
personal hypocrisy a personal history of
not being a particularly good person
completely ignorant on the issues I mean
there there is no checklist of things we
should try to keep out of public office
that doesn't include everything that
Herschel Walker is so let's make sure if
you vote in Georgia make sure you
understand where and when to vote there
is a lawsuit currently about early
voting if you can plan to vote on
December 6th plan to vote on December
6th we will be live with
um election results and all of it on
that day I've had such trouble finding a
great razor where I am not cutting
myself for getting those Nicks on my
skin which are so common with the cheap
disposable razors you have to meet our
sponsor Henson shaving Henson actually
manufactures parts for the International
Space Station and the Mars rover and
they are bringing that exact same
Precision Engineering to the Shaving
experience it hurts when you shave
because blades extend too far and thus
they wobble slightly but with their
Aerospace grade CNC machines Henson is
able to make metal razors that extend
just
0.0013 inches that's less than the
thickness of a human hair which means a
secure stable Blade with the vibration
free shave it also has built-in channels
to evacuate the hair and the cream no
more clogs no more rubbing your thumb on
the razor sure to get the hair out I use
Henson at home shaving is a great
experience now Henson wants to be the
best razor not the best razor business
which means you only need to buy it once
and it's awesome go to hensonshaving.com
Pacman add a razor and a hundred pack of
blades to your cart then enter the code
Pacman to get the hundred blades for
free that is a three year Supply the
link is down below